[Music]
well did joe biden challenge his fellow
americans to a nuclear arms race
what's happened is that there are never
been if you wanted to think you need to
have weapons to take on the government
you need f-15s and maybe some nuclear
weapons
i don't know if you know this but the
people are responding americans are
rushing out in record numbers to buy
f-15s and nukes to fight off the
government
but not really you see that headline was
a joke from the satirical website the
babylon
b the babylon b uses comedy to help
raise concerns over real issues like in
this instance the president pointing out
that he was effectively threatening
americans with nuclear war again
maybe not really joining me now the man
behind this website ceo of the babylon b
seth dylan seth thanks for being here um
i don't know what the headline here is
that
joe biden is in an arms race with we his
fellow americans or he's bad at history
i mean i think the taliban just fought
off a nuclear power for 20 years
with guns well what we're supposed to
believe
is that a group of un unarmed a huge
unarmed group of trump supporters
stormed the capitol building and we're
about to topple the government so
apparently that
was possible just a few months ago now
we need jets and nukes
totally unarmed people almost toppled
democracy
by charging the capital on january 6. by
the way on that note of
a a superpower taking on an upstart
ragtag group of people
you guys had an awesome headline at the
babylon b i want to put it up for
everyone this is an op-ed by the way
written by king
george you'll never beat a tyrannical
government with just
guns nice one there said
yeah i mean it's just uh the messaging
here is so mixed isn't it
but this is exactly the messaging you
would give to people if you want to
encourage them to buy more guns
and bigger guns that's right i
understand also there at the babylon b
and i do want to get to a serious issue
or a little more serious issue with you
in just a moment
but i understand you have a new
documentary out as well you've
you've found um the latest trend in
transports it's motorcyclists who
identify
as bike lists watch
i had always known that something about
me was different
there was something wrong after a lot of
thought
and reflection i finally realized that
my life
as a motorcyclist was a lie
i was a bicyclist joining the race is
norm hiccup
wait i thought he raced motorcycles
[Music]
i never felt better free to be my true
self live
my truth just be me
i don't you know man i don't know if the
culture has
moved your way or you just hired all the
talent away but somehow
you are in a better position than any
other comedic organization right now to
point out the absurdity of our culture
well this is the thing in this case
we're speaking truth to power this stuff
is coming from the top down these are
the most powerful people
in government and corporations this
progressive
ideology and these progressive values uh
are being imposed on us
all the way from the top so we see this
as speaking truth to power but
a lot of people are are suggesting that
these jokes are punching down and i have
a hard time
uh grappling with that and understanding
exactly what they mean by that
uh you know that's that's one of the new
lines of attacks against us at first it
was
we're spreading misinformation now we're
punching down at people that we
shouldn't be attacking
but that's just a way of them protecting
their sacred cows and and i honestly
think it's pretty condescending to
suggest that
uh you shouldn't joke about certain
people because they're beneath you yeah
in fact i think the new york times had
to have you or tried to have you pushed
off of facebook and other places
under the guise of misinformation you at
the babylon be sued you're quickly
reinstated because you are satire you
are comedy
hey one last point out of personal
curiosity seth so
a few years ago people said
conservatives couldn't be funny there
was no source of conservative humor and
maybe to some extent they were right
there wasn't a big cultural
a real cultural pocket for that what's
changed i mean one thing i noticed has
changed is the people that used to be
funny by the way who all were on the
left
they're not funny anymore so what's
changed yeah
well they did a lot of the changing i
mean they they started making all these
things off limits that you can't joke
about for one thing so they began to
censor themselves
and they began to try to censor other
people um so when you
when you start to have this this culture
and climate where people like jerry
seinfeld are avoiding doing comedy shows
on college campuses because everybody
wants a safe space and doesn't want to
be offended by anything you've really
changed the landscape there so they're
having a hard time being funny
dancing around all these issues they
have to avoid uh and so that creates an
opportunity for people to come in and
say
say the things you're not supposed to
say the politically incorrect jokes
you're not supposed to make
so i think they opened up a huge uh
gateway there for people to come in
and uh and take some of that market
share and people have the babylon bee
more facebook engagements than the onion
go follow the babylon bee check out
their site you're missing out i promise
you
if you're not seth dillon thanks so much
for jumping on with us tonight
thank you appreciate it hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else